well I SARS idea would read boris
pasternak which is a famous Russian poet
won a Nobel Prize before every match and
he kind of captures that ethic so this
is the poem I'll say it in Russian okay
and then in English please okay Draghi
reporter vamoose lado Prado - I put
Cepeda patch lapa regina at poppy adidas
some need da janela chat he doesn't
needi need ok yet post-its at itza no
bridge jovem Java Metallica Java
Metallica the concern I know there's a
bunch of Russian people that appreciate
that the translation a bit crappy is
very difficult to translate the Russian
language but it's the others step by
step we'll follow the living imprint of
your feet but you yourself must not
distinguish your victory from your
defeat and never for a single moment
betray your credo or pretend but be
alive only this matters alive and
burning to the end so this is at the end
of a poem that represents the fact that
Fame that most of the poem says that
same recognition money none of that
matters the winning and losing none of
that matters what matters is the purity
of the art just giving yourself
completely over to the art so like
others will write your story others will
tell whether you did good or bad others
will inspire using your story but as the
artist so in the case of Pasternak he's
a poet writer it did Road in Doctor
Zhivago
the is the art you should only think
about the art and the purity of it and
the love of it
you